i can ask you about something you
mentioned in terms of psychiatry when
you were younger
because i had a similar experience
of you know
reading freud and uh called young and
just you know those kind of popular
psychiatry ideas and that was a dream
for me early on in in high school too
uh like i hope to understand the human
mind by
like somehow psychiatry felt like
the right discipline for that
does that make you sad
that psychiatry is not
the the mechanism by which you want to
are able to explore the human mind so
for me i was a little bit disillusioned
because
of how much
prescription medication and biochemistry
is involved in the discipline of
psychiatry as opposed to the dream of
the the freud like
use the mechanisms of language to
explore the human mind so that was a
little disappointing
and and that's why i kind of went to
computer science and thinking like maybe
you can explore the human mind by trying
to build the thing
yes i wasn't exposed to the um
sort of the biomedical slash
pharmacological aspects of psychiatry at
that point because um i didn't
i dropped out of that whole idea the
physical pre-med that i never even found
out about that until much later
but you're absolutely right that's uh so
i was actually a member of the um
national advisory
mental health council that is to say the
board of scientists who advised the
director of the national institute of
mental health
and that was around the year 2000 and in
fact
at that time the man who came in
as the new director i had been on this
board for a year when he came in
um
said okay
schizophrenia is a
biological illness it's a lot like
cancer we've made huge strides in curing
cancer and that's what we're going to do
with schizophrenia we're going to find
the medications that are going to cure
this disease
and we're not going to listen to
anybody's grandmother anymore and
you know
good old behavioral psychology is not
something we're going to support
any further and um
you know he
he uh
completely alienated me from the
institute and from all of its prior
policies which had been much more
holistic i think really at some level
and and basically and the the other
people on the board were like
psychiatrists right
uh
very biological psychiatrist it didn't
pan out right that that that
nothing has changed
in our ability to uh
to help people with mental illness uh
and um
so 20 years later that that that
particular path uh was a dead end as far
as i can tell
well there's some aspect to
and sorry to romanticize the whole
philosophical conversation about the
human mind but to me
psychiatrists for time held the flag of
we're the deep thinkers
in the same way that physicists are the
deep thinkers about the nature of
reality psychiatrists are the deep
thinkers about the nature of the human
mind and i think that flag has been
taken from them and carried by people
like you
it's like it's more in the cognitive
psychology
especially when you have a foot in the
computational view of the world because
you can both build it you can like
intuit about the functioning of the mind
by building little models
and being able to say mathematical
things and then deploying those models
especially in computers to say does this
actually work
they do a little like experiments
and then some combination of
neuroscience where you're starting to
actually be able to
observe
you know do certain experiences and and
human beings and observe how the
uh
the brain is actually functioning and
there
using intuition you can start being the
philosopher like richard feynman is the
philosopher a cognitive psychologist can
become the philosopher and psychiatrists
become much more like doctors they're
like very medical they help people with
medication by biochemistry and so on but
they are no longer the
the the the book writers and the
philosophers which of course i admire
the i admire the richard feynman ability
to do
great low-level uh mathematics and
physics and the high level philosophy
yeah i think it was uh
from and young more than freud that was
sort of initially kind of like made me
feel like
oh this is really amazing and
interesting and i want to explore it
further i actually
when i got to college and i lost that
thread i i found more of it in
sociology and literature than i did in
any place else so i took quite a lot of
both of those disciplines as an
undergraduate
and
you know i was actually deeply
ambivalent about
the psychology because i was doing
experiments
after the initial flurry of interest in
why people would occupy buildings during
a insurrection and consider you know uh
to be be sort of like so over committed
to their beliefs
but i ended up in in the psychology
laboratory running experiments on
pigeons and and so i had these profound
sort of like
dissonance between okay the kinds of
issues that would be explored when i was
thinking about
uh
what i read about in
in modern british literature
versus what i could study with my
pigeons in the laboratory
that got resolved when i went to
graduate school and i discovered
cognitive psychology and and so for me
that was uh
that was the path out of this sort of
like extremely sort of
um ambivalent divergence between the
interest in the human condition and and
uh the
desire to do
you know actual mechanistically oriented
thinking about it
um
and i think we
we've come a long way in that regard and
that uh
is you're absolutely right that
nowadays this is something that's
accessible to people through
um the pathway in through computer
science or the pathway in through
uh neuroscience
um
you know you can get derailed in
neuroscience down to the bottom of
the system where you might find the
curious of various conditions
but you don't get a chance to think
about the higher level stuff so it's in
the systems and cognitive neuroscience
and
computational
intelligence miasma up there at the top
that i think these opportunities are
most
are richest
right now and so yes i am indeed blessed
by having had the opportunity to
fall into that
space
you